the long snouted seahorse a rare
encounter in the waters off plymouth
this tiniest of animals is clinging to
strands of seagrass
vital for its protection and survival
this is a habitat and also a species
under critical
threat it's only hope the efforts of
volunteers from the ocean conservation
trust
seeding and growing new sea grass
meadows
rewilding the ocean floor if you look in
there look
yeah that's the seeds oh yeah
so it's a marine flowering club
and there's an added benefit seagrass
draws carbon out of the atmosphere
using it to photosynthesize providing a
nature-based
defense against climate change plants
capture carbon forests and they create
this
this complex ecosystem environment for
all sorts of wonderful wildlife so
rather than spending vast amounts of
money on on creating
um expensive carbon capture techniques
just
look around in the night in the natural
world and there are
organisms all over the face of the
planet that will store this carbon for
well you could just about make out down
there the tidy green
shoots seedlings of an idea with vast
potential
the pilot project aims to grow 80 000
square meters of new sea beds over the
next four years
it's thought up to 92 percent of uk
seagrass has been lost to pollution
disease and human disturbance
it's hoped that the success of this
project will lead to scaled-up versions
along coastlines
all over the world but as world leaders
from the g7 meet
in cornwall not far from here and with
the uk hosting the next big climate
conference in november
the message is that so much more still
needs to be done
marine biologist jason hall spencer says
that restoring marine wetlands
is only a partial solution to the much
wider problem
of human impact on our oceans well we
know that there's only about
2.7 percent of the ocean is actually
protected from damaging activities and
it needs to be more like 30
so that's my key message to the g7
ministers and leaders
the ocean stores more carbon than
anywhere else and there's more carbon in
the seabed than there is
in the atmosphere and trawling that up
and releasing it into the sea is bonkers
what we need to do is stop those
activities and allow the sea
bed to recover new seagrass beds have
much to offer
small vulnerable species and the
environment
but progress here will mean little on
its own
jonah hull al jazeera plymouth